I made only three videos on this
channel, and all of them got over
100,000 views. Believe it or not, it all
comes down to these four steps. I
already explained how I use storytelling
to get more retention. Now, it's time
for step two.
You ready? If no one clicks on a video,
they don't watch.
Point of a thumbnail is to create a
journey
from the thumbnail to even the
high-quality images are crucial.
Add some intrigue.
I make people want to know what happens
next.
make any sense. We need to make better
thumbnails.
I don't mean these guys are wrong, but
let's be real. You already know all
these basics. Even if you don't, they're
just common sense. Do you really need to
be told to keep your thumbnail simple
five different times in five different
videos from five different gurus? I
guess not. So, here's the full guide on
how to actually make a thumbnail that
gets clicks. We will go from the design
rules I use to thumbnail types, getting
inspiration, branding, word choice,
visual effects, testing, and
The first rule is pretty simple, but it
takes your design from a mess to a piece
of art. Just take any popular YouTuber's
thumbnail and draw four lines like that.
Do you see what's going on there? Almost
all of them, even my thumbnails, follow
these lines at the core. Well, you might
know the rule of thirds from
photography, which basically says put
the objects over these lines to get a
nice shot. That's why almost every
channel has a thumbnail like this,
because it works. So, just add those
lines to guide you throughout the entire
design. Trust me, it's a game-changer.
We'll come back to the layout, but
before that, we need to choose a color.
You probably heard people talking about
the color wheel. The idea is to get
enough contrast in your thumbnail. You
should choose two opposite colors from
this circle. And if you dive deeper, you
would see there are more techniques
that's used to get fancy combination,
but here's the plot. I don't use them.
There's a much easier way to find a
color for your thumbnail and for your
entire channel. So, here's what I do.
Take any color you like as your main
color. I chose yellow for mine. Then,
add three more, one black, one white,
and one in the middle. You can slightly
tweak these to match your main color,
but I like to keep it simple. And
finally, add another color to highlight
things. There we go, a color palette
that's actually useful. Even though my
sister says it looks like a Minecraft
house made from diamond and gold, I like
it. You can use it in your editing, too,
but that's for another video. Now, you
might ask, wouldn't that be too
repetitive if I use the same colors in
all my thumbnails?
That's right. The solution is simple,
just change the highlight color. That
way, you can keep the fresh vibes while
still being recognizable by your
viewers.
It's simple, just pick a basic font that
isn't overused, and you're good to go.
For those who are asking, the font I use
is called Eastman, and it looks pretty
good.
All right, we talked about the rule of
thirds and how to make a good layout.
It's nice, but you can't just invent
something new in this square for every
single video, right? Well, you don't
have to. If you paid attention while
browsing on the home page, you may
already have catched some thumbnail
types that most YouTubers are using.
Shout-out to this legend for breaking
them down into 21 categories. But here's
the best 10 that will work for 99% of
the time.
YouTubers like Airrack and Mr. Beast use
that style all the time. But even if
you're not an entertainment channel, you
can still use this type of thumbnail.
Take a look at this. Hey, what's he
doing? Dude, put that chicken down. Oh,
this is how airplane engines are tested.
They test it with chickens? See, that's
the target emotion of these thumbnails.
Just shock the viewer while scrolling on
the home page and make them click. It's
easier to say, but think about what you
have in your video that would shock the
viewers.
Of course, big things always get more
attention. Don't take this out of
context. People are curious to know what
a $50 million house looks like or how
this dude earns $900 just by listening
to music until they realize he doesn't.
Among all those over-edited and
screaming thumbnails, another way to
stand out is keeping it really simple.
Just an interesting chat from Discord, a
chair, a red button, or this thing.
Whatever this is may get more attention.
It's usually just a screenshot from the
video and a simple question that makes
you curious to know what's going on.
Channels like Doctor Insanity or Zach
are doing it so good that it makes it
impossible to skip.
If you're a small channel in a popular
niche, social hacking is probably the
best way to gain the first traction.
Basically, take the face of a famous
person in your niche and slap it into
your thumbnail. Oh, the video must be
about that person though. Otherwise,
it's called clickbait. All the videos
you see with Mr. Beast's face are using
the strategy and it works pretty well.
Even Dream used it in his first videos.
So, don't underestimate the power of a
popular face. All right, let's speed
things up.
This is the style you see all over
YouTube. Just the creator next to
something bigger.
Yeah, the one I use in this channel.
Basically, an interesting text at the
top to give more context about the
video.
It can be anything to compare to. Before
and after, something cheap versus
expensive, iPhone versus Android, pin
versus AI. You got the point.
Blurring the main character or the final
result so people have to click to find
out.
I don't know if you realize, but all of
those viral thumbnails that I showed in
this video and even all the ones that
you saw in your homepage have one thing
in common. They're not just using one of
these formulas. They're combining them.
Look at Mr. Who's the Boss's series
where he buys every release of a tech
like iPhone or PlayStation. I showed you
this in big numbers, but if you look
closer, you would see that he also uses
header comparison and even social
hacking formulas all at once. Or take a
look at this chair. Which types could
you spot? It's branded because of their
logo right here. It's simple because,
well, there's nothing else than a chair.
And it's using social hacking because
everyone saw on chair at least once. We
can even include it as a weird object if
you think chairs are weird. Even I used
big numbers and header styles in my
first video on this channel. I wouldn't
say it's very creative, but it worked
for sure. I can go on with all the
thumbnails that I showed, but the idea
is choose two or three styles, combine
them, and try to stick to it for around
five videos. It will make your audience
understand it's your style, but don't
stick to it for too long because using
the same formula 100 times would
probably make the viewers feel like you
just keep repeating yourself, and it
will lower the chances of click unless
you're a reaction channel.
Well, it's one of the most popular
advice that you can hear from YouTube
gurus. Just look what other YouTubers in
your niche are doing and try to
replicate it, but I completely disagree
with that, and I have evidence to
support my opinion. Take my first video
as an example. Trying YouTube shorts is
definitely not a unique video idea. What
about the thumbnails?
That style seems to work for many
people. Well, in that case
Aha, you're a smart guy. Just copy what
works, right? The problem is you're not
the only one.
That is the worst thing to do. If you
see many similar thumbnails from
different channels about the same topic,
hopping on that train is probably not a
good idea. If so many channels are
already doing that, it's the cliché
thumbnail now, and your audiences are
basically the same. So, there's no
reason for people to click on your zero
view video instead of their 100K. Even
worse, people will probably notice
they're too similar, and you might
become just a copycat of your
competitor. So, what should you do then?
You can't reinvent the wheel for each
new video, right? Well, just kidding. Of
course, it's not really possible to do
that. If you're posting consistently,
sooner or later you'll run out of
thumbnail ideas, and when that happens,
you should just look at channels outside
your niche. For that video, I went
through the channels I follow in
completely different niches and came up
with this thumbnail. Same thing applies
to almost all of them. So, get
inspiration from the channels with
different niches. That will make your
video stand out from the crowd because
your audience with those channels are
different, but it's the same with all
these other channels. So, when it
appears alongside those, yours will be
much more likely to get more attention.
Experimenting with new things is always
good, but just try to keep the core
elements like colors, fonts, and style
consistent. That makes your audience
notice your video on the home screen way
faster and with enough time boosts the
CTR.
This is where you got to be creative.
You can use a big number if that suits
your video, a bold statement opposite of
a common belief, or just a title that
represents your video. If nothing fits
well, leaving it blank is always an
option.
Congratulations, you just learned how to
make a viral thumbnail.
Right?
I don't think so.
Look, you learned the theory, which is
really important, but it doesn't mean
anything if you don't know how to use
them. Most people will probably close
the video at this point, take all that
information, and go make a thumbnail
like this.
But if you stick around, you'll learn
how I turn this into this. Hey Finn,
what do you call it?
Photoshop, baby. Photoshop, baby. How do
you say it like that? With just a few
simple effects and some ancient
Photoshop sorcery that I learned from
this guy. Yeah. Hey everyone, I'm still
here. Got stuck in this timeline.
Dude, you need to work on your jokes.
Photoshop sucks.
After choosing your concept and
sketching a detailed draft on paper,
open Photoshop. Create a new project,
get your line, add your character, text,
a nice background, and other elements.
It already looks better than that.
Make the text fancier by double clicking
here. Then, change the color, add inner
glow, outer glow, and whatever this is.
Just tweak the settings to make the
unique effect you want. Here are the
adjustments that I usually do if you
want to get a similar style. After
you're happy with the look, save it as a
new style to use it next time. You can
do that for other elements, too.
It's the effect that I used in this
thumbnail to bend this chart. You can
bend anything by just clicking the
corner of an image and choosing this
button. Now, you can warp it however you
want.
Looks good, but they seem too
distracting in the background. Let's add
some blur. Select the image, filter,
blur, Gaussian blur. That might work,
but we can do even better. Let's try
again. Select image, filter, pixelate,
mosaic. Oh, we made it worse. Again.
Again.
That's it. Even though these blurs might
not suit this thumbnail, they work very
well in some cases. So, it's nice to
know how to use them. All right, let's
move on.
We fixed these images, but the
background is too shiny. It's almost
hard to read the text.
So, we need to make it darker. Take the
brush. Woah, woah. Calm down. You don't
have to be a Bob Ross to use this, okay?
Just try to keep up. Make your brush big
and soft. Reduce the flow to something
like 5% and increase smooth. Now, open a
new layer on top of your background and
start painting behind text, character,
and things like that. Okay, we're
getting somewhere.
That background image looks nice, but I
don't really like the color.
I said, but I don't really like the
color.
How to change it? Glad you asked. Select
the background. Click image,
adjustments, hue and saturation. Here,
you can choose a specific color to
change or tweak the entire image. Noise.
We're almost done, but I'm looking so
unnatural over there. I mean, the text
above my head is shiny. There should be
some light reflections in reality,
right?
Pick the selection tool. Select the
thing. Create a new layer. Take the
brush. Make it smaller. Pick a nice
color and brush over where the light is
coming from. Oh, don't forget to change
the layer blending style to overlay. If
it doesn't work for your image, try
other styles and colors, too.
After everything's done, I like to send
it to my phone, play around with the
colors in Lightroom. So, it goes from
this to this.
Before publishing the video, you need to
test how it looks on YouTube homepage.
To do that, go to thumbsup.tv. Add your
title and thumbnail and see if it looks
good. If it does, you're good. If not,
go back to the drawing board again. But,
hopefully it does.
Here it is. I know, it's probably not
the best way to make a thumbnail, but
that's just how I do it at the moment.
It will definitely change with time, but
for now, this is all I do and it works
for me. So, it may work for you as well.
Photoshop, baby.